♪ (intro music) ♪
Give me one minute
and I'll show you how Cloud Logging
can help you better understand
your infrastructure and apps
by aggregating and visualizing log data.
Cloud Logging collects log data
from Google Cloud services automatically,
or any custom log source
through Cloud Logging agents,
APIs, and client libraries,
and gives you complete control to decide
how and where to store the logs.
Once the logs are in Cloud Logging,
the Log Router funnels them
to Cloud Storage or BigQuery
for analytics,
or streams the logs via Cloud Pub/Sub
to custom third-party destinations.
Log Explorer gives you
powerful capabilities
to find the logs you're searching for.
You can also use Cloud Logging
to convert logs to log-based metrics
for monitoring, alerting,
analyzing, and visualizing.
Your error logs sent to Cloud Logging
are automatically analyzed
by Error Reporting
to give you a centralized
error management interface
that counts and aggregates
application crashes and errors.
From a security perspective,
all your data is encrypted
at rest and in transit.
All your security focused
immutable Audit Logs
are automatically available
in Cloud Logging,
telling you who did what, where, and when.
And with Access Transparency logs,
you can always stay in compliance,
because it captures the actions
Google personnel takes
while offering you support.
You can use the Cloud Console APIs
to use Cloud Logging.
It comes with a very generous free tier
to make it easy for you to get started,
and affordable pricing thereafter.
So next time you're looking
to use logs for troubleshooting,
take a minute to look at Cloud Logging.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/logging